النعاس والارهاق ضعف التركيز وانخفاض
الاداء الوظيفي كلها اعراض شائعه في نهار
رمضان وسببها الرئيسي اضطرابات النوم من
ساعات راحه قليله او متقطعه لتقليل هذه
الاضطرابات هناك عده نصائح اولها القيلوله
قبل الافطار بشرط الا تتعدى 30 دقيقه اي
قبل دخول في مرحله النوم العميق حتى لا
تؤثر على النوم ليلا ويفضل النوم بعد صلاه
العشاء لاربع ساعات قبل الاستيقاظ تناول
وجبه السحور ثم النوم لمده ساعتين
اضافيتين بعد الفجر وقبل الذهاب الى العمل
النشاط البدني في النهار يمكن ان يساعد
على النوم بسهوله اكبر اثناء الليل وافضل
الاوقات لممارسه الرياضه يكون قبل ساعه من
الافطار بشكل عام ومن اجل نوم افضل تنصح
ايضا مؤسسه النوم الوطنيه في الولايات
المتحده بابعاد الاجر الالكترونيه
كالتلفزيون والكمبيوتر والهواتف الذكيه
غرفه النوم
[موسيقى]